Madame de Barra a rédigé un dernier testament le
20 juin 1845 quelques mois
avant de mourir chez elle à San Jie Liu
le 4 février 1846. Le
soussigné CV Mohanty bling va
faire Moombah veuve de monsieur le pieu
lampe Ananda beza propriétaire vivant  au sajal
quartier d'échantillon disposé à user de la
faculté qui m'est accordée par le Code Civil
article 1075 et faite par ce testament
et d'après ce qui suit le
document a été consommé aux
archives départementales de la Réunion il
établit une liste précise des
biens qui laisse  à nos neuf
enfants cinq petits-enfants et six
petits-enfants le Testament est
intéressant en ce qu'il décrit parmi les
biens ce qui fait la
petite propriété des Senji en particulier 295
esclaves Malaga Z et kafir mais surtout
créoles nés à l'île Bourbon
ce film d'animation montre  une
lecture orale partielle du Testament mais
énumérer pleinement dans les foyers ou
affiliations indigènes les fonctions et la valeur
estimée des esclaves attachés à la
propriété